I think everyone knows about
the beauty of joseon sunscreen
if you don't it is super popular
right now because it's so light
and comfortable while still being
protective and really budget friendly
but beauty of joseon has so many other fantastic
budget-friendly skincare products some of which
are really underrated I'm going to tell
you about some of the best ones today
I'm Michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and most importantly skincare connoisseur
let's get into it
this video is sponsored by StyleKorean
who stock K beauty products from tons
of different brands including beauty of joseon
i'm going to start with possibly the second most
hyped up beauty of joseon product although I still
think it's less popular than it should be it
is the revive eye serum ginseng and retinal
this is an eye product but a lot of people
actually just use it all over their face
the main drawcard here for most people
is the retinal which is considered the
strongest form of vitamin A that you
get in cosmetic skin care products
it's only one conversion away from retinoic
acid so it's one step closer than retinol
korean products tend not to use a lot of
vitamin A but it is starting to increase
I think this is still the only korean
product I've seen that has retinal
it is one of the if not the most
budget-friendly retinal products available
this has 0.02% retinal encapsulated in
liposomes which makes it a really gentle product
basically the retinal is inside
these little packets and it gets
released more slowly onto skin the
liposomes also help keep it stable
and there are also soothing
ingredients in this there's
niacinamide ginseng vitamin e and adenosine
all of these help reduce a bit of that
irritation and the ginseng is also meant
to have some anti-wrinkle benefits this is
one of the gentler retinal slash retinol
products I've tried but I do know that
some people have still gotten irritation
from it so if you're new to these stronger
retinoids or if you know that your skin
finds retinoids a little bit spicy I would
recommend introducing this really slowly
I have a video on how to start
on retinoids that have a lot of
tips for how to slowly introduce your skin to it
but I have found that I can use the
serum every day if I'm just a little
bit careful with it and don't use like
way too much which is how you are meant
to use retinoids you only need about
a pea-sized amount for your whole face
this is fragrance free I know a lot
of people whose skin can't handle
fragrance often have issues finding k
beauty products so if that is you boj
should be on your radar because most
of their products are fragrance free
and this leads me onto the radiance cleansing balm
I am a huge fan of cleansing balms I really enjoy
them for melting off makeup and sunscreen sort of
effortlessly before then using a regular cleanser
I just find it really relaxing to like massage
my face while I take my makeup off at the end
of the day it is honestly my favorite step in my
skincare routine that I look forward to all day
it's kind of like the face or skincare
equivalent of kicking off your shoes
a lot of people have asked me about fragrance
free cleansing balms that have smooth textures
that still rinse off nicely and this
is one of the the very few out there
and unlike a lot of other fragrance-free
cleansing products this actually barely
smells like anything it still has that really
lightweight kind of melty texture that a lot
of other korean cleansing balms have minus
the fragrance so if your skin is sensitive
to fragrance then this is a really good
option that doesn't really compromise on much
the tub also has this really handy flip
top lid which is much nicer than a screw
top when your hands are like oily and
slippery it has a spatula if you are
into spatulas I'm not really that into
spatulas I find it really satisfying
to just like gouge my finger into
the whole of the cleansing balm
I do get a lot of products with
spatulas I've actually got them
in this giant collection right here
I don't know if anyone's noticed this
anyway this is a really nice product
and I think it is relatively unique
now on the topic of cleansing let's move
on to the green plum refreshing cleanser
this is a really lovely inoffensive cleanser and
inoffensive is really what
you want from a cleanser
you want it to clean well without messing up your
skin so your skin is nicely prepared
for the rest of your skincare routine
it also foams really well but
it doesn't dry out your skin I
would say that this is actually one of
the most hydrating cleansers I've used
there was zero tightness on my
skin after using this there are
a bunch of antioxidants in it which can
potentially help reduce a bit of that
cleansing irritation and it is slightly
acidic to match your skin's natural pH
with a lot of foaming korean cleansers you
tend to get this really amazing fluffy dense
foam but then they have a really high
pH and that tends to help strip your
skin and irritate it if your skin is prone
to dehydration which my skin very much is
it does take a little bit more effort
to get like a fluffy lather with this
compared to those more drying cleanser
formulas but I think it is really worth it
I am a huge fan of hydrating cleansers because
it feels like you don't need to use as many
hydrating products after cleansing you don't have
to load up your skin again with hydrating toners
and serums just to get your skin back to baseline
before you go and apply the rest of your skincare
again this is a fragrance free cleanser so another
really good option if your
skin doesn't like fragrance
I feel like I have already raved about the
relief sun rice + probiotics so many times
but I'm going to quickly run through it in case
for those of you who are new to beauty of joseon
this is possibly the most raved about
sunscreen online at the moment and
it is my favorite sunscreen that
I've tried so far it is a korean
sunscreen that's not approved in
other countries as far as I know
it is pretty lightweight but on the more
moisturizing side which I have personally
really appreciated my skin is sort of oily
combination but it has been drying out a bit
because I've been using a lot more retinoids
which are a bit drying and I've also had
some hormonal changes thanks to dealing
with endometriosis the texture is really
beautifully smooth and buttery it's made by
one of korean's top sunscreen manufacturers
there is a tiny bit of white cast when I first
apply it but it goes away once
I leave it for about 10 minutes
on the topic of rubbing and white cast you
shouldn't be rubbing your sunscreen in a
whole bunch to try to get rid of that white
cast the more you rub the more it drops the
protection of the sunscreen it can drop it by
quite a lot so just put it on and let it sit
the downside of the sunscreen is that
because it is so popular there's been
quite a few fakes floating around like
on amazon so if you are planning to buy
this I highly recommend buying it from
an official retailer like stylekorean
my next pick is the apricot blossom peeling gel
is it just me or is everyone
sleeping on peeling gels?
I feel like I don't really
see other skincare creators
talk about them but maybe I just haven't seen them
let me know in the comments if
you're a peeling gel fan or if
you know where all the peeling gel fans are hiding
I've been using a peeling gel maybe two or three
times a week for or more than the
last 10 years maybe the last 15
peeling gels are one of my top
underrated products that I really
feel need more love and this is a really good one
they are basically really
gentle physical exfoliants
the reason everyone hates on physical
exfoliants is just that a lot of people
tend to overuse them and that is pretty
easy to do if they've got really rough
particles things like apricot seed or
ground pumice or like salt particles
a lot of people start using scrubs when
they start on skincare they're looking
for something to deal with acne
and then they just use those and
use them way too hard and that just
irritates the crap out of their skin
that also happened with overusing cleansing
brushes which is another
form of physical exfoliation
and all of this has just given
physical exfoliants a really bad name
but physical exfoliation isn't all bad
it's actually really fantastic
for immediately smoothing the
surface of your skin when you use it in moderation
that's the important part
moderation
and if you have a physical exfoliant that's
really gentle you can probably use it in
combination with chemical exfoliation
without overly stripping your skin
and of course that will depend on your skin
so that's why peeling gels are great
they have the softest cellulose
fibers as they're scrubbing particles
these are the same sorts of fibers
that you see in wet tissues when
they're sort of like falling apart
and so these are super soft fibers
that aren't going to scratch your
face no matter how hard you press
when you put one of these on your skin
the oil from your skin starts making
the fibers bunch up and turns them
into larger soft scrubbing strings
there are some products that say
it is dead skin but it is not
if it was dead skin it would not be a
gentle product and even though those
fibers are really soft I find
that they're really thorough
peeling gels are just really good at getting dead
skin off my skin compared to something
that feels a lot harsher like a scrub
a standard scrub that has hard
particles and that's especially
in the parts around my nose
where it kind of feels like
it's hard to get to with a physical
exfoliant this just works really well
now if you press too hard you can
still end up irritating your skin
because you just have way too much
friction but you have to try a lot
harder to overuse a peeling gel and they
have made such a difference to my skin
one little use case that I love is when I have
dry flakes around my nose like when I'm blowing my
nose a lot I've had a cold or I've had allergies
and then I put on foundation and the foundation
gets caught in the flakes and it makes them look
really obvious if I have a peeling gel and I use
it really gently just buffing it in little circles
and rinsing it off before putting on makeup
that stops this from happening
and it kind of breaks off the
flakes really close to the skin
and yeah exfoliating irritated skin is not really
best practice but it is a lot better than the
alternative which is me trying to pluck off like
foundation colored flakes with a pair of tweezers
afterwards which ends up ripping off skin that
is still attached and leaving raw exposed skin
it's really gross and if you are
someone who also does this please
do yourself a favor and use a peeling gel instead
this is one of my favorite peeling gels I've tried
my big test of whether a peeling gel is good
is whether or not it bunches up and gives
enough scrubbing fibers when I use it in the
shower when there's lots of extra water around
this one works really really well but a lot
of them don't and they turn kind of sad and
watery some of them actually go kind of
sticky and stick to all your like little
hairs and maybe that's why people don't love
peeling gels they've been using the wrong ones
but yeah this one passes with flying
colors and again it is fragrance free
and it has minimal smell for a fragrance free
product which again is rare for a peeling gel
now what is actually best practice
for irritated flaking skin is
*segue*
a hydrating product
this is the ginseng essence
water it's a hydrating toner
this sort of product is really popular in asian
skincare for just adding a layer of lightweight
hydration to your skin without adding
stuff that sits noticeably on the surface
this doesn't leave any residue on your face so
there's just a lot less chance of this making
another product ball up on your skin so this
is perfect for under sunscreen or under makeup
it's also really good as one of the
earliest steps in an evening routine
I would apply this right after cleansing
before any other actives or serums
it's also really handy when your
skin is really dehydrated and
your regular moisturiser isn't quite doing enough
so instead of trying to find a whole
new moisturizer you can just add
another hydrating product underneath
and together they can hydrate enough
I found this super useful for applying to
my skin right after cleansing it stops my
skin from drying out if I wait a
bit too long before my other steps
this is super hydrating it's got
a lot of glycerin it's also got
hyaluronic acid and it leaves a kind of
plump hydrated feeling on my skin that
is just shy of being tacky and that is
such a hard balance to get in a product
like that maximum plumpness but just not
sticky although I can't guarantee that it
will hit that spot for everyone else it
depends on how humid your environment is
it depends on your skin but it does hit
that spot for me so there is a chance
there's no extra oil in this either
so again just less stuff on your face
there are a lot of different types of
ginseng extracts in this which have lots
of antioxidants as well as niacinamide so this
is a really good way of adding niacinamide and
antioxidants and ginseng to your routine
without adding much weight or stickiness
the lack of oil is also awesome for
when you need something in summer to
just hydrate and soothe your skin but you
can't handle any extra oil on your face
I use this as my hot weather moisturizing
product at night a lot and just skip moisturizer
again it is fragrance free and
to me it smells like nothing
beauty of joseon have a bunch of
serums and out of them my favorite
one that I've tried so far is the glow
serum which has propolis and niacinamide
it took me a really long time to get into propolis
because I always just assumed it
was like the same as bee venom
it just sounded like a really irritating
ingredient that was meant to be good for
acne and nothing else and I felt like I
already fell into that trap with all those
teenage acne products that just burn
so I avoided it for a really long time
but it turns out that propolis is like the
opposite of that it is really non-irritating
after I saw kelly driscoll rave about propolis a
whole bunch of times I finally decided
to look more into it and try it out
and it turns out that my skin really
loves it and this is actually one of
kelly's top serums which is why
I tried it in the first place
kelly is really good for k beauty reviews I end
up loving a lot of the products she recommends
propolis is really nice and soothing it's great
for breakouts and I think that's because it
is made from plant sap the bees basically eat
it and turn it into concentrated antioxidants
it's also really hydrating and humectant
it has a bit of a sticky texture but in
a lot of products it is diluted enough
so it's not really offensively sticky
this isn't sticky but it does have
that tacky hydrating texture there's
also two percent niacinamide and 0.5%
salicylic acid both of these are great
at evening out skin tone which is
one of those components of glow
someday I might do a proper video
breaking down exactly what glowing
skin actually is but basically this serum
ticks off a whole bunch of boxes for it
even skin tone smoother skin and hydration
this is just a really lovely product that I use
on my face when I want my skin to look smooth
and even the next day without having to risk any
irritation and it is one of the few products that
I can use for that when my skin is irritated
without having to worry about making it worse
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
did hit the like let me know if you
tried any of these products
before and what you thought
if you want more product reviews you can
check out this playlist where I've ranked
reddit's top asian skincare products thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time